today we're going to talk about the six
early signs of um
what was that um
dementia now before i begin i want to
tell you a little story about what
happened when i was in practice and this
relates to early signs of dementia that
weren't really early signs of dementia
you see when you're stressed or tired or
maybe you didn't sleep you could have
all of the symptoms of dementia but not
really have
dementia and the worst thing you could
do is give your spouse or partner
the wrong diagnosis or even diagnose
them at all that's really really bad and
this relates to a couple that came in my
office quite some years ago
with early signs of dementia and as i
was talking to husband i asked him
when did you first
notice signs of dementia he said i'm not
sure but i think it was when my wife
started to diagnose me and i was like oh
okay and i noticed when they were
sitting there they were going back and
forth and the husband was having
problems remembering certain things and
his wife was constantly correcting him
and telling him
honey you forgot again and uh you're
mixing up your words and etc etc and so
i was brutally honest and i actually
just told her that's going to make
things worse every time you remind
someone that you made a mistake
you're just going to lock it in and
they're going to keep making the mistake
over and over and over so i pulled the
wife to the side and i i said i want you
to do an experiment i want you to just
let him make mistakes and just don't
correct him at all for one week and when
they came back after a week it was quite
amazing because
he was articulate he was sharp he didn't
seem to have any cognitive dysfunction
at all
so i just want to bring that up because
when i cover these six signs
it doesn't mean that you have dementia
if you have these occasionally and if
you know someone who has these symptoms
just realize it could be sleep it could
be
their blood sugars it could be any
number of things that is not real
dementia all right that being said what
is dimension it's a mental decline and
what's usually happening is certain
parts of your brain are atrophying
they're shrinking
specifically a structure called the
hippocampus which i'm going to
talk about in a little bit but here are
the early signs okay
you have difficulty
organizing and planning things you have
personality changes okay there's a
change in personality but again that can
happen in for any number of reasons
number three and this is interesting
constipation now realize just because
you have conservation does not mean you
have dementia but it is one of the early
signs
simply because of the connection between
the gut and the brain your gut is like a
second brain you have more nerve fibers
in your digestive system than you do in
your spinal column and a lot of
cognitive problems
actually can stem from your gut the
microbiome in your gut all those
bacteria
make neurotransmitters
in fact those little microbes make more
serotonin than your brain makes
serotonin and people that have
alzheimer's or parkinson's have a much
higher incidence of constipation
than someone who doesn't have those
issues then the next symptom would be
sensory
dysfunction that can include issues with
smell
taste
hearing
your eyesight and it can also be your
appetite all of these could be
some of the early signs of a cognitive
decline and as it declines more and more
and more
the ability to focus the ability to
concentrate
and your overall memory is what really
shows up as being a problem all right
number five language problems which i've
already mentioned
like you're trying to um
find words for certain things you tend
to repeat things over and over again or
you might be mixing up your words
this is a problem with the hippocampus
and there's a lot more to this topic
that i'm not going to get into in this
video but like there's one symptom for
example that a person is able to talk
and make sentences totally fine but it's
incoherent what they're saying does not
make sense and i'm sure that's extremely
frustrating because the person is trying
to get out this communication but it's
coming out very randomly and all over
the place this is mainly a problem with
this hippocampus and the hippocampus is
just
shrinking i'm going to show you what to
do if you have this problem or you know
someone who has this problem and the
last sign of early dementia is the
inability to navigate well in new places
so let's say for example you're going
into a new
place you're trying to find a store and
you just cannot
for the life of you find this location
this is because in our brain we have a
gps that allows us to locate where we
are in space and when this area goes
down
you lose your gps so
your internal map is dysfunctional and
you just cannot find out where you are
so if you have a problem with that that
could be an early sign of dimension all
right now i'm going to show you seven
things
that you need to do
to correct this okay before it becomes
more advanced the best time to correct
this is right now
in these early stages as compared to
waiting before it becomes a real big
problem and i think you can correct it
if you get it early enough but the big
problem in medicine
is the lack of
importance
or significance that your diet makes
in this area of your body they don't
seem to connect the dots between the
great importance of what you eat and how
that can affect your brain they're more
like well this could be genetic could
just be some stress things just happen
and there's really nothing you can do
about it your diet is key in preventing
and even reversing dementia if you can
get it early enough alright so the first
thing to know is
what would shrink your hippocampus okay
a really common cause of
a problem with hippocampus especially
when in atrophies is a thymine
deficiency that is a b1 deficiency and
you can look this up it's well known but
usually that can happen from
alcohol but it can also happen when
you're on a high carb diet if you're
consuming a lot of carbohydrates you are
going to deplete vitamin b1 so the more
sugar you eat the more carbohydrates you
consume
the more
b1 your body needs the demand for
thymine goes way up when you consume
carbohydrates because you need vitamin
b1 to metabolize carbohydrates
and the more alcohol you drink the more
b1 you need as well so number one start
taking b1 and nutritional yeast
is the best source of b1 and just make
sure that you get the kind that's
not fortified with synthetic vitamins i
recommend going on the natural side
because synthetic vitamins might work
initially but they're not a good
long-term solution now of course you
also want to do things that will prevent
a b1 deficiency and that would be
not drinking alcohol anymore and also
giving up some of these carbs
but i have some good news you can
consume
vegetable carbohydrates right so that's
exciting all right let's switch to
number two and i've already kind of
talked a little bit about this but you
want to fix the gut the microbiome
there's some real interesting research
on alzheimer's and parkinson's and there
seems to always be a lack of diversity
in the microbiome
there always seems to be gut
inflammation in these patients as well
so one of the important things to do is
to increase the diversity of the
microbiome and one of the best ways to
do that is to start consuming different
types of vegetables not just one type of
vegetable over and over and over like
just salad but if you're going to do
salad have a wide variety of different
types of salad different types of fibers
that have different phytonutrients that
can then
strengthen different strands so that's
one way another way is to do fasting
fasting increases the diversity of your
microbiome now you would think if you
starved off the microbes they would get
weaker but they get stronger and you
have new strains that just kind of come
out and start to
thrive it's part of the survival
mechanism that has been evolving for for
eons now also realize that your gut and
your brain is bidirectional okay through
the vagus nerve you have information
going from the gut to the brain and
information going from the brain down to
the gut so
if you have a problem with your brain
you're gonna have a problem with your
gut if your problem with your gut you
can have a problem with your brain and
like i said before
a good amount of the neurotransmitters
are produced by your microbes a good
amount of the b vitamins are made by
your own microbes and
there's been some really good research
on
getting people off gluten and seeing
huge improvements in dementia and so
gluten can actually worsen dementia and
i'm not just talking about going on a
gluten-free diet i'm talking about going
in a low-carb no grain diet and one
little point about gmo foods foods that
have been exposed to glyphosate which is
an herbicide which is connected to gmo
foods are not good for your brain simply
because glyphosate
works by destroying
microorganisms certain pathways in
microbes like bacteria well guess what
that can affect our microbes just like
it affects the microbes in the soil so
you do want to start consuming more
organic foods non-gmo foods all right
number three and this is pretty powerful
i found some great research on consuming
more sprouts like broccoli sprouts that
have sulforaphane now unique thing about
sprouts is that they come from these
little seeds okay
and if you were to consume the seed it
would be first of all not very available
to you as far as the nutrition in it and
so it's very difficult to digest but
when it sprouts you have incredible
amounts of nutrition that's released and
so if you're consuming sprouts on a
regular basis
you're not only getting some of the peak
nutrition that a plant has but you're
also getting certain phytonutrients that
are not just anti-cancer like i've
talked about in other videos they are
super food for your brain so
sulfurophane in broccoli sprouts
is fantastic for any type of
neurodegenerative
disorders plus sprouts
are really good for your gut and with
alzheimer's patients and parkinson's
the incidence of
leaky gut is also very very high so
include sprouts in your salad on a
regular basis and they're very very
cheap to to grow yourself all right
number four and this is also very very
important
ketones ketones bypass
the damage in the brain and feed the
neurons directly because think about
what's happening in the hippocampus
you're getting destruction of your brain
cells so we need to restore that we need
to feed the brain cells
fuel so apparently at that stage it's
not getting glucose fuel
so if you feed it ketone fuel it can
thrive and so if you have any stage of
dementia at all you need to be doing
regular intermittent fasting as well as
periodic prolonged fasting and you're
going to see
huge benefits
and for two reasons number one is that
you're going to generate a lot more
ketones than you would even if you want
a low carb diet and you're also going to
up regulate all sorts of genetic factors
that support your brain now i also
recommend
consuming like mct oil you can also do
exogenous ketones you can buy these
ketones as a supplement and so you just
take like one tablespoon of mct oil
maybe twice a day and that will help
your brain a lot all right dinkle biloba
has shown some significant
benefits for dementia patients
specifically the extract e g b
761
so apparently that extract gives you
some significant neural protection to
your brain all right number six this is
a good one
lion's mane mushroom you know mushrooms
are just fascinating the research done
on lion's mane it's just off the charts
as far as
impacting your cognitive function i mean
it's not insignificant it's it creates a
huge impact on your brain so i'm going
to put that information down below and
then there's the usual recommendations
that i always talk about in my videos on
your brain
that would be the omega-3 fatty acids
specifically dha
found in fatty fish and fish oil and
especially cod liver oil then you also
have vitamin d which has a huge impact
zinc very important exercise something
else that's very important to increase
oxygen to your brain
and sleep if you're not sleeping
you're going to jack up cortisol you're
going to be more stressed and you're
going to deplete the brain of oxygen now
if you haven't seen my recent video on
the brain
you need to check this out i put it up
right here